on this sunday night
canada's place in the vaccine lineup
the delays of doses extra beds is like a
band-aid what we really need
is a vaccine are more options imminent
for canada
the concerns the pandemic could worsen
those variants could overtake
and lead to a much more devastating
third wave and how to prevent it
a new zealand woman tests positive for
kova 19
after the two-week quarantine and
heeding the call for help
i thought oh that's my thing the medical
professionals
coming out of retirement
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us it's going to be a tough week on the
vaccine front
no new doses are arriving from pfizer
biontech
the prime minister says he's received
assurances from the company that it will
follow through
with deliveries when production gets
going again
but a member of his cabinet and a close
confidant of justin trudeau
is hinting two other vaccines could be
approved in the near future
but will it make up for the delay
abigail beeman has our top story
i spoke with the global ceo of pfizer dr
borla
a conversation that didn't change the
fact canada will get zero doses of the
pfizer biontech vaccine this week
the next few weeks will be challenging
when it comes to deliveries
according to the federal government as
of last thursday more than 1.1 million
vaccines were distributed to the
provinces and territories
and according to the global news vaccine
tracker by sunday
a little more than 800 thousand of those
were administered
on the world stage canada continues to
drop in terms of vaccine rollout
now ranking in 18th place right behind
italy
and romania extra beds is a
like a band-aid what we really need is a
vaccine
we are in an international competition
for a very scarce resource
on the west block with mercedes
stevenson the minister of
intergovernmental affairs said the
government is trying to get moderna
doses
earlier whether they can bring forward
some doses that may
be coming in april could we get them in
march some of the ones that were coming
in march can we get them in february
so those conversations are ongoing
literally on a daily basis
also hinted at a timeline to approve the
next two vaccines
we're very hopeful that in the coming
weeks other vaccines may be approved by
health canada as safe for use
astrazeneca perhaps johnson and johnson
thereafter
coming weeks for the two vaccines under
rolling review by health canada
both are more traditional vaccines than
the new mrna technology used for pfizer
biontec
and moderna meaning the world could
produce more fast
they can use industrial processes that
we already have a pretty good handle on
they're the type of things that can be
made in large batches
and for lower cost than something like
an mrna vaccine
canada's top doctor is asking all
canadians who are vaccinated to keep
following guidelines including
mass use and physical distancing in part
because dr teresa tam says while the
vaccine will stop you from having covet
19 symptoms and getting sick
we still don't have enough evidence as
to whether it stops you from
transmitting the virus to someone else
abigail beeman global news ottawa
there are concerns that new highly
contagious variants of kovit-19 could
push canada into an even more dangerous
third wave some health experts say more
aggressive steps need to be taken
and the clock is ticking catherine ward
reports
we've got a chance in canada because it
hasn't
arrived in huge numbers here yet but the
windows closing
even though thousands of tests for covet
19 happen every day in canada
that is not the case for the new variant
commonly referred to
as b117 or the uk variant
we look at about three to five percent
of cases but we're going to miss
at the moment 95 to 97 percent of
of these variants when they appear in
canada a second
sequencing test is needed to confirm if
a coveted 19 case
is the b-117 variant at the moment that
is only being done when it is highly
suspected
this was the case at the long-term care
home in barrie ontario just north of
toronto where officials say nearly all
residents and staff
have tested positive we've had a
preliminary
test showing a mutation that was
consistent with one of the variants of
concern
now we know that the variant in this
question is
the uk variant and on sunday another
case of the uk variant with connections
to a long-term care home was confirmed
in bradford
officials say countries that do the
additional sequencing will have a
clearer picture
of what they're dealing with when it
comes to the spread of the virus
and be in a better position to get the
pandemic under control
there's much more sequencing going on in
england that's that's really why we
discovered this variant
and other countries like denmark
announced this week they're going to now
sequence every positive case
experts warn if more is not done this
highly transmissible form of the virus
could quickly get out of control this
gets into places where there's
vulnerability
there's going to be a significant amount
of spread and yeah there's going to be
hospitalizations but unfortunately
deaths
you know those variants can grow
exponentially
in a background even where cases are
decreasing and that's a real concern
because those variants could overtake
and lead to a much more devastating
third wave catherine ward
global news toronto ontario and quebec
remained the kovit 19 hot spots in
canada but a promising trend is starting
to emerge in quebec
daily case numbers and hospitalizations
are declining
but as tim sergeant explains it is still
a time to be cautious because only 2.5
percent of the province's population
has been vaccinated the impact of the
government ordered
lockdown is still clearly evident most
montreal stores malls
and restaurants remain shuttered
quebec's premier is lauding the benefits
of the overnight curfew
the extraordinary measure the first of
its kind in canada has been in place
since
january 9th daily covet 19 cases
and hospitalizations are dropping but
the number of patients in intensive care
remains high
and the death toll continues to climb
it's always difficult to see somebody
die
dr jean-francois is the icu director of
a leading teaching hospital in montreal
he says this is no time for quebecers to
let down their guard
or for the government to ease
restrictions we'll still have to
to do what we did for the last nearly
year
and protect ourselves because the virus
is still there montreal police broke up
three large religious gatherings this
weekend all of them occurring at
synagogues
attended by the city's hasidic jewish
community the police acted appropriately
from everything that we've been told and
everything that we've seen and heard
and it's a source of pain to the jewish
community what happened
the fear is that large public gatherings
like these can become
super spreader events you might be doing
something for a very good reason but
that doesn't matter in terms of viral
propagation so
i think we have to be mindful of the
fact that anytime people get together
there is a risk of viral spread
administering the covet 19 vaccine is
the government's strongest weapon in its
battle against the virus
to date all seniors in public nursing
homes have received a first
dose but in the rush an error
ninety-seven-year-old antonieta dibiase
received the moderna vaccine at her
nursing home
but when she moved to a different
location her second dose was a pfizer
vaccine
it's a combination that is not
recommended by pharmaceutical companies
or public health officials whoever's
giving out these vaccines
is the one who should be blamed so far
only two and a half percent of the
quebec population has been vaccinated
for now the curfew and lockdown measures
remain the key to containing the coveted
spread
we don't want to open things up and have
the numbers climb again
the government imposed restrictions are
scheduled to be lifted on february 8
but that date could likely be extended
tim sergeant global news montreal a
family which came to canada as syrian
refugees is mourning the death of their
19-year-old son
after he contracted kova 19. he worked
as a cleaner at a long-term care home
where several residents have succumbed
to the illness as morgan campbell
reports
an investigation is now underway into
the young man's death
yesin debay was a cleaner at the
middlesex terrorist long-term care home
outside of london ontario
he died last week after contracting
covet 19.
this has totally broken my heart it's
pain
after pain tragedy on tragedy mohamed
faki
is a well-known business owner in the
province and has deep roots
within the islamic community he is also
one of many people across ontario
feeling the effects of debay's death at
19 years old
he is the latest person under the age of
20
to die with covet 19. of the 19 000
people that we've had die
due to covet only three of them are lost
are 19 years and under so this is three
three deaths out of nineteen thousand so
it's extremely rare
the teen was a contract cleaner at
middlesex terrace
in a statement the ceo of the home's
parent company
offered condolences writing we extend
our deepest sympathies to the family and
friends of yasin
out of respect for their loss and grief
we are declining any interview or
statement requests
at this time global news has learned
that the teen was a syrian refugee
arriving here in canada
back in 2016. the islamic community has
come together
in support of the grieving family
covering all costs associated
with the funeral the middlesex london
health unit has confirmed an
investigation is underway to determine
if the teen
had underlying health conditions a
person of this age
diagnosed with covid would rarely have a
fatal outcome such as this
so it certainly is saddening and
tragic debase death comes at a time when
the province is grappling with outbreaks
in more than 250 long-term care homes
middlesex terrace is currently battling
an outbreak at the 105 bed facility
where at least a dozen seniors have died
and more than 50 residents and staff
members
are infected many could have been
prevented
with adequate staffing adequate care
levels
adequate infection control and ppe
advocates say the latest death is
troubling in all 11 ltc workers in
ontario
have died from the virus in addition to
more than 3 300
residents morgan campbell global news
near london ontario
to the u.s where an astonishing 25
million people have been infected with
covid19 since the start of the pandemic
and there is growing frustration among
americans waiting to get their shot
but the white house is asking for
patience as jennifer johnson reports the
new administration is optimistic
about its vaccination plan it's really
horrible
frustration across america as coven 19
vaccines run out
with no notice this woman's appointment
was canceled in brooklyn
there was like no signage on the street
this is where we are or we're canceled
depending on which state or even which
county you live in dictates who can get
the vaccine right now and who can
retired surgeon gave me my shot so i'm
very happy
under the trump administration's rollout
plan it was every state for itself
but that is changing with the new
president the biden administration has a
new federal plan
but facing a multitude of challenges we
need more vaccine we need more
vaccinators we need more vaccination
sites
and in the by demonstration we're
tackling all three the food and drug
administration has just approved new
special syringes
that can extract one extra dose from the
pfizer vials
adding more shots to the supply
meanwhile despite republican opposition
democrats think they can get the
president's new 1.9
trillion dollar covet 19 relief package
passed
as early as next month we've got people
with pre-existing conditions that have
been literally isolated
for nearly a year waiting for help with
this vaccine
of course we need the funding to get
that vaccine distribution
out there we got to stop messing around
and get our economy going again
the president spoke with u s governors
this weekend asking them to push their
residents to wear masks
as they get this vaccination plan up to
speed
masks not vaccinations are the single
best
defense that we have medical experts say
that by wearing masks by warren mask
from now
until april we will save more than
50 000 lives
the biden administration trying every
defense possible against this virus
knowing that hitting their 100 million
vaccination mark will take
months to pull off jennifer johnson
global news
washington for the first time in more
than two months
new zealand is reporting a case of kova
19 after the patient in question was
quarantined for 14 days
the 56 year old woman had recently
returned from europe
and during the mandatory two-week
isolation period
she tested negative twice health
officials are now conducting
genome testing to confirm if her case is
a more transmissible variant of the
virus
coming up getting 11 miners trapped 600
meters underground
out
one by one 11 miners were rescued today
in eastern china
they had been trapped for two weeks
after the explosion at the gold mine in
the province of shandong
rescue crews had been communicating with
the miners and lowered food and medicine
to them
through lifeline holes drilled through
the rock but the ordeal isn't over yet
the condition of 10 others trapped in
another part of the mine
is still unknown and sadly one person
injured in the initial blast was
confirmed dead today
at the start of the pandemic retired
nurses answered the call to return to
the front lines and help save lives
now they're needed again to improve
sluggish vaccine rates
ross lord explains the effort to
vaccinate more canadians
faster is touching off a different kind
of call to arms
and among those heeding the call are
retirees who thought their days on the
front lines were over
i thought oh that's my thing i would
really appreciate doing that
teresa anderson of sarnia ontario came
out of retirement
suddenly she's working full-time hours
driving more than an hour to london each
day
to vaccinate grateful recipients i've
never really had this in my career
before where
people just literally run towards you
run to you to get that vaccine and they
sit down and they're
just just so happy and relieved that
they're getting this
injection in nova scotia this union
leader says she's ready to get up from
her desk
and into a vaccination clinic we should
do our part and volunteer to do
immunizations and that's what i've done
i've completed the education component
to as a refresher
as an incentive the nova scotia college
of nursing is waiving fees
and re-licensing nurses faster than ever
this is
just a wonderful opportunity that we're
hearing from these retired nurses
how thrilled they are to have this
opportunity i wanted to be
part of that and to be able to support
our community getting
vaccinated and for us
as a society to get back to whatever
level of normalcy
we will have post this covetera the
college says in the past week alone
roughly 200 nurses have applied to
return
a movement that's growing across canada
as the push for protection
intensifies ross lord global news
still ahead a single rocket breaks a
ride-sharing record
on your marks get set
people across england spent the day
enjoying a rare snowfall despite
current lockdown measures parks were
filled with kids and some adults
sledding down hills many people were not
wearing masks or physically distancing
but at least one snowman spotted near
buckingham palace
was sporting a mask the snowfall forced
several covet 19 testing and vaccination
centers to shut down
so far more than 6 million people across
the united kingdom
have received their first dose of the
vaccine our europe bureau chief crystal
commansing has a look at the race to
vaccinate in the uk
and around the world from cathedrals
to cinemas vaccination centers have
sprung up around the uk
strange but it's strange times isn't it
nice and open
plenty of space for everybody boris
johnson's government is aiming to
vaccinate
15 million in the over 70 and high risk
group by mid-february
the urgency more acute now that there's
some suggestion the uk
variant may also be more deadly
like in canada there are also supply
issues
here some communities are having their
vaccine shipments diverted to other
neighborhoods
the goal is to balance coverage but it
is frustrating for people
if we think about this as being a kind
of a wildfire if we're all kind of going
at this with you know with our
individual jerry cans or our hoses and
trying to kind of put things out you
know piece by piece
we're not going to make a lot of
progress i think we have to think about
this as being a non-competitive race
in countries with robust vaccination
campaigns the uk and israel for example
infections hospitalizations and deaths
remain
very high researchers in israel grabbed
headlines saying early data from some
older individuals
vaccinated with the pfizer biontech
vaccine suggested
single shots may not provide as much
protection
possibly only lowering the risk of
infection by 33 percent
pfizer biontec has not released any
single dose
data its trials were based on two shots
the commons have since been refuted by
israel's minister of health saying the
information was taken out of context
and that more time is needed for the
vaccine to take full effect
still officials in quebec took note
they're watching for more information
but for now
the province's vaccination strategy is
not changing
the problem is there's little concrete
data
research is ongoing it's been somewhat
frustrating i think for
most of the research community kind of
watching this kind of science by
press release teams around the world
need time as they work to sort out
questions about vaccine effectiveness
and the role coronavirus variants play
public health experts continue to say
vaccines are a key
tool but not a silver bullet stressing
the need for people
to take precautions still keep yourself
safe follow the guidelines
if i stay indoors much longer
it's for everyone's safety being safe
will keep the virus from spreading
crystal gamson global news london
spacex achieved a record-breaking bride
share today
after it launched 143 satellites into
space
the most ever carried by a single rocket
in history
in the process the falcon 9 rocket
deployed 10 of the company's own
starlink satellites as part of spacex's
ambitious satellite internet plans
after completing its mission the rocket
safely landed back on earth
on the same day up next the loss of a
leaf's legend
george armstrong's role in hockey
history
is off now armstrong is good
[Applause]
toronto hockey legend george armstrong
has died at the age of 90.
armstrong spent his entire nhl career
with the maple leafs
he captained the team to four stanley
cups in the 1960s
armstrong was one of the first players
of indigenous descent to play
professional hockey
he was inducted into the hockey hall of
fame in 1975.
a boy in new brunswick is getting big
league attention for a small scale
zamboni
five-year-old nicholas alain went viral
for cleaning his family's backyard ice
rink with this
improvised mini zamboni made by his dad
the video's popularity has snowballed on
social media
even catching the attention of the nhl
it shared the image on its instagram
page
and that is global national for this
sunday i'm robin gill
we leave you tonight with getting cold
for a good cause
this is how we do a snow challenge in
alberta canada
these canadians are making snow angels
in swimsuits
and daring others to do the same to
raise awareness for the heading to 2022
campaign
the goal is to raise money to help
researchers find a cure for diabetes
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back here tomorrow i'll see you
next weekend
have a great night